greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
and thank you for joining me today we're
gonna talk about SEO tools let's get
started so if you're doing SEO and
you're doing on-page and off-page SEO
for an organization or website you're
going to need some tools to help you so
you can't go at it alone you can't do
anything manually you have to lean on
tools to help you work more efficiently
help you gain an advantage and so if
you're doing SEO you're gonna need tools
for keyword research
you're gonna need tools to help you with
the technical aspects related to SEO
you're gonna have to use some tools for
off page SEO including backlink
monitoring and analysis and then there's
tools for helping you track where your
keywords and pages rank so there's tools
for every element of SEO and today we're
gonna take a look at some of the best
tools out there on the market to help
you do your job better so let's start
with the keyword research so with
keyword research tools you can do your
job a lot more efficiently finding the
right relevant keywords I mean that's
really key to SEO is finding keywords
that are relevant to your business
product or service that you want to rank
for so you want to be able to choose
keywords with high search volume and low
competition so where do you get those
numbers you get those from certain tools
you also want to get forecasts for
certain targeted keywords you want to be
able to generate a list of latent
semantic indexing type keywords keywords
close to the keyword you're trying to
target you want to be able to select
primary and secondary keywords wisely so
having a list of keywords or certain
data points will help you do that and
you want to be able to identify the
keywords that your competitors are also
ranking for so good keyword research
tool will help you do all of those
things so what are some of the tools out
there well look no further than some of
the free ones thank Google Offers like
Google Trends so Google Trends is a good
tool that you can lean on if so if we
look at Google Trends all you need to do
go to trends Google com you could type
in a keyword I can look at the volume or
interest of that keyword over time
I'm here I'm looking at football vs
American football and I could see how
it's trending then I could see you know
how it ends in specific regions of say
the United States as my market I can
also look at other related queries
similar to football or American football
and so Google Trends is a good tool
helps you look at the volume helps you
look at what specific regions help you
look at other keywords you know if you
want you could simply just do a keyword
search or you can actually just see
what's trending just by looking at the
latest stories and insights so we could
see International Women's Day you know
started a pick up steam it's picking up
more steam etc so it's certain keywords
that tend to trend well and you could
pick up on what those keywords are using
Google Trends now you could also use
another Google tool called Google
Keyword planner the only difference is
this one's paid you need a Google Ads
account so if we go into Google Ads hey
you'll need to go to tools and you'll
need to a keyword planner but when
you're in keyword planner you can find
new keywords so if I type in for example
you know online marketing and click get
started what the keyword tool is going
to do is give me the data that I need to
do appropriate keyword research it's
going to give me my keyword and similar
keywords it's gonna give me the average
month and volume and the great thing
here is I can actually see the trend for
that keyword over time just by clicking
on this little bar graph so for digital
marketing I can see what the trend is
over time I can see what the competition
is I could see you know if I'm going to
bid on this keyword I can see what the
bidding range is some more important I
can see the volume and I can see the
competition there's my volume for this
keyword over the last 12 months on
average and here's my competition so
Google's keyword planner gives you the
necessary information you need to choose
relevant keywords wisely now there are
other tools out there that are paid that
help you look for relevant keywords like
SEM rush or keyword finder
that's a freemium tool so there are
plenty of tools available to you you
know another tool I use that's not
listed here is Moz so if you just type a
keyword let's just type in the sink
like online marketing for example okay
so what Maz is gonna do it's gonna give
me some volume it's gonna give me some
other keyword suggestions okay it's
gonna tell me how difficult that keyword
is and it's gonna tell me who else is
ranking for that keyword so it gives me
again all the relative information I
need including competitive information
so you can use these teeth these keyword
tools Moz is freemium some are paid some
are free there's plenty of tools out
there but these the ones I would
recommend for keyword research now let's
turn our attention to technical SEO so
for technical SEO you're gonna need to
use some tools there's no getting around
that because you want to be able to
monitor how your website is performing I
mean is it loading slow for example does
it have a lot of issues with the website
in terms of server-side rendering for
example or server response time what
about four fours and redirects
so you want to be able to gather a lot
of the technical information that could
aid or prohibit your site from ranking
so you want to be able to also you know
look at what the bots are seen and how
they're viewing your website so if
Google goes to crawl your site are they
experiencing you know slow server
response time or they experiencing pages
not found you also want to see if you
have a sitemap you know what's the
sitemap are these bots crawling your
site or getting the pages from a sitemap
again you want to be able to lean on
some of these tools to help you fix
errors that you may encounter like meta
tags or for fours or Canonical's so you
need a good tool to help you manage all
that and so I'm gonna go back to my
starting out so if we go back to moms
mas is a good tool it's an all-in-one
it's a great SEO platform so if I go to
Moz and I log into an account I can just
go to site crawl and so what Mama's is
gonna do it's gonna give me a lot of
information about how Moz is bought is
seeing my site okay so if I go to the
site crawl I can look at all the
particular critical issues that I've
experienced so I could see for for
errors okay redirects related to that I
can see meta descriptions missing meta
descriptions duplicate content so
there's a lot of different issues that
Moz is the
Dean for this particular site and the
great thing about Moz and this is why I
use Moz as my SEO platform I don't work
for Moz I've just used them a long time
is if you do have issues then they give
you ways to fix it though how to fix it
section so if I see missing description
here if I just click on review and get a
more in-depth analysis as to what the
issues are here but I can also click on
the why and how to fix ok and they're
gonna give you some information about
how this is impacting SEO and what you
could do to fix the issue they lay out
the issues pretty prominently here you
can see for all the metadata issues I
have I have you know 142 total metadata
issues I have ten title tag two Long's
I have 122 missing meta descriptions so
they lay it out nicely here up the top
so you can kind of get a sense of what
to work on
and again they prioritize it based on
the severity of the issue and then they
break it down into several categories
for example I just looked at metadata
issues you can see if I click on content
issues I have some duplicate content
that Moz is recognizing or missing or
valid H tags so Moz does a really really
great job laying off all the issues out
for you to recognize okay there's
another tool that I like to use called
screaming frog it's a paid tool so if we
go look here great thing I like about a
screaming frog it will crawl your site
and it will give you some list of issues
just like Mazdas of you know what it
sees in your site is experiencing four
fours broken links are there any
redirects it's picking up duplicate
content sitemaps you know they're draw
the script issues how does it see the
site architecture so it really does take
a deep look at everything that could
impact your website from ranking okay
there are other tools out there like you
know deep crawl or will rank they're
both paid and so paid tools are really
great as well it just depends on you
know your pricing structure what your
budget is but really when it comes to
all these tools they all more or less
overlap and do the same thing you just
need to rely on
one of them to make sure that you're
able to see what the issues are now
there's nothing wrong with using two of
them just as a second reference point to
see if both are picking up the same
issue of course I like to use search
console I always like to lean on Google
search console because that is the
source so search console will also you
know give you some feedback on how
Google's bot is crawling your site so
that's under the crawl error section
here so you can also you know use search
console to upload a sitemap so that's a
key to SEO you want Google to be able to
find your webpages quickly so you can
simply just signify to Google where your
sitemap is located so the search console
does a lot more gives you some HTML
improvements gives you some backlinking
and then the process of updating their
search console use your interface so
there's a new user interface that you
can use with Google search console the
great thing is it's free and it has
everything you need to know about your
website and how it's affected by SEO
organic search the only thing you have
to do with search console is verify the
site well once you verify it it has all
the relevant information you need so
let's talk about backlink monitoring and
analysis okay so this is related to off
page SEO so you're gonna need a good
tool to help you monitor your website
backlinks and backlinks are simply just
links from external sites pointing to
your site and you need to keep an eye on
what sites are linking to yours are they
spammy related sites are they good
relevant sites or anything in between so
you need to really be able to analyze
what this good links are what the bad
links are pointing to your website and
you can also you know given the tool
also perform some competitor analysis so
you should be able to use a tool to be
able to compare how your site's ranking
against your competitor and you want to
measure the ratio referring domains to
backlinks so how many pure domains are
linking to your site so you want a tool
that's gonna be able to tell you that
you want to identify and disavow port
backlinks okay so you want to be able to
recognize what sites are linking to
yours that's actually hurting you from
an SEO
standpoint and you want to be able to do
something about that hey you want to
measure citation flow and trust flow you
want to check the ratio of link
distribution in terms of is an internal
or external or you know what kind of
sites are linking to my side are they
you know social related are they pure
content related and then you want to be
able to track the number of do follow
and no follow links you know how many
links pointing to our site are actually
telling Google and other BOTS not to
follow the link or how many are actually
allowing the bots to follow that link if
a bot follows a link it's going to pass
what we call link juice so you're gonna
get credit for the backlink if it's a
nofollow you're not gonna get credit for
the backlink and we want to be able to
measure that and so we wanted to have
tools that will help us do that so what
are some of those tools well h refs is a
good tool it's a pain tool Majestic is a
freemium tool Moz again Moz is the tool
I use SCM rush and then again I gotta
mention Google search console so let's
take a look at some of these tools in
terms of backlink monitoring and
analysis so let's start with Google
search console again it's free you just
have to verify your site and so if I go
to Google search console I can look at
links and I can see what external links
I have pointing to my site k so I can
see I have 17,000 in this example
pointing to the home page of this
particular site okay so if I click on
that I can see all the the top sites
pointing to my home page now from an off
page SEO perspective do you want every
backlink or external link pointing to
your home page now so you want links
pointing to internal pages so you want
to be able to measure that so I can see
with the top linking sites are and I can
also see what the anchor text is so do I
want my anchor text always to be my
brand name no I want it to be you know
keyword we're trying to target search
console also gives you some internal
links okay what if top linked pages for
internal links so from an SEO
perspective you always want to have a
nice balance of internal linking so this
report helps you understand what pages
are getting links and are the links
evenly spread so this is Google search
console this is the links report this is
totally free this is provided by Google
all you have to do is verify your site
now if we go over to Moz we type in a
domain any domain so I just typed in
simple and learn okay Moz has some
metrics that are important to off page
SEO including domain Authority so the
higher your domain authority the better
off you are
and so what helps a domain Authority
grow is how many quality links are
pointing to that domain and so here we
can see over 7500 linking domains to
simply learn so what's important is we
just don't want any site we want quality
relevant sites pointing okay so we could
see how many total inbound links and
then how many ranking keywords we have
okay so here Moz is gonna give me kind
of an idea of what my domain Authority
has been over time they're gonna tell me
the top followed links to the site so
they can tell me you know what are those
links pointing to my site and what's the
page authority of those sites okay here
I can get a nice graphical breakdown of
the linking domains by domain Authority
so you want pages with high domain
Authority pointing to your site so here
I can see 69 linking domains between 91
and 100 so that's really good we want
high relevant domains linking to our
site so just like search console I can
see the top anchor text being used okay
and I can see the top pages that have
you know good page authority on the site
I could see following verses nofollow on
internal and external links so this is
just the overview so Moz really really
does break down for you
you know what those pages and linking
domains are so if I just click on
linking domains now I could get a
detailed look or my home page
what domains are pointing to our domain
so I can see Microsoft com has a domain
Authority of 100 you 299 and so not only
does Moz provide you with the domains it
also provides you with their domain
authority score and spam score so you
want to keep an eye on any particular
site that has a high spam score so
having a site with a high spam score and
a low domain authority will hurt your
domain and page Authority for
Paige so Maz does a great job of
breaking it out and this is for any page
it doesn't necessarily have to be the
home page okay if I take a look at
another example here majestic so
majestic and I can use a free version of
the tool they have their own metrics
citation flow trust flow so when they
say trust flow what's the link quality
all about okay citation flow what's the
link volume and they can get an idea of
how many external backlinks are pointing
to the site and what's the trend on that
referring domains so majestic does a
really good job again some of the same
metrics that we can see here except they
go into detail about languages as well
so this is majestic and you got search
console you got a lot of other tools and
then I'm gonna just revert back to Moz
because you want to be able to compare
link profiles if you're in a competitive
space and you're doing off page SEO you
know Moz will help you compare how your
site stands against maybe another
competitive site or relevant site so
just doing this analysis I can compare
my domain Authority spam score how many
total links you know how many external
follow links or external nofollow links
a breakdown of linking domains so it
does a nice job of comparing one site
versus another that's going back to Moz
and that's what you want you want a good
tool that's going to help you do that I
mean there's other tools out there not
listed like bright edge that will also
help you compare linking profiles so at
the end of the day if you're doing off
page SEO you want to get a sense what
sites are linking to yours are they
quality sites are they spammy what
anchor texts are they using are they
nofollow are they do follow you know are
they top domains how do you compare
against your competitors I mean all
these metrics are related to off page
SEO so you want a good tool that's gonna
help you measure this okay so let's talk
about rank tracking so we do keyword
research
we're looking for relevant keywords we
find all relevant keywords we sign
primary and secondary keywords to pages
we optimize those pages we do off page
SEO and we do in all this work for SEO
okay we want to be able to measure the
fruits of our labor we want to
be able to measure how we perform for on
and off page SEO for the keywords we
covet in the pages they're related to
and so that's where rank tracking comes
into play so we want to be able to track
our website's ranking and not just our
website all the pages we've optimized we
want to be able to measure our click
your rates and impressions we want to be
able to track the ranking for both
desktop and mobile for specific
locations and we want to identify top
performing gaining and losing keywords
so in other words we want to look at
trends is a keyword ranking is it going
up and ranking is it going down and
ranking if it's going down and ranking
then you need to take action so you need
a tool a good tool for rank tracking so
we can look no further than again Google
search console it's free it's right from
the source so let's take a look at what
Google search console has to offer in
terms of rank tracking so if I go to
google search console and I put in a URL
what it's going to do is it's going to
give me and this is the search queries
report it's gonna give me what queries
people have used to actually type into
Google comm and it's gonna be able to
tell me how many times my pages show
pages showed up for that query it could
be more than one page that's an
impression and if I did receive an
impression meaning did my page show up
in the organic listing then did I get it
click as a result and so in this case if
I got 68 impressions and 10 clicks for
keywords somebody typed in that's a
14.7% click-through rate and so what
search console will also do is say hey
look for that particular keyword you
appeared on average in position 4.1 so
it gives you really good insight as to
you know what people are typing in and
how you're being found for those
keywords it breaks it down by pages it
breaks it down by country breaks it down
by device so I could see you know mobile
I had 899 impressions over the last
three months on mobile and I received 33
clicks as a result my
position on mobile was 2.6 so search
console does a really good job again
this is free information providing you
the actual keyword somebody's using on
Google search as a query and how many
impressions you're receiving for that
keyword how many clicks click the array
in the knavish position so in theory the
higher you are positioned on Google the
more clicks you're gonna receive so if
I'm not positioned properly for keyword
let's say say page two then I'm probably
not gonna receive as many clicks as I
would like so that's search console
there are other tools out there like H
refs again does a good job of tracking
amz tracker we look at win shirt so
there's some good tools out there I'm
just gonna show you another one again
I'm gonna go back to Moz for example so
Moz has a tool called so if I go back
into the account so Moz has a a rankings
tool that you can look at to see where
your keywords are ranking so if you've
already chosen keywords and optimized
pages for those keywords then you want
to be able to load those keywords in a
Moz and so Moz allows you to do that and
so what Moz does they do it crawl once a
week and they'll be able to tell you
where you rank for all your keywords are
we moving up in the rankings are we
moving down how many keywords do we have
rank between positions one and three
eleven through twenty four through ten
twenty-one through fifty so we'll be
able to see where our keywords rank and
so it gives you a breakdown here of
nationally in the United States where
this keyword is ranked and if it's moved
up or down and for what you're rel is it
ranked four and so you can label soak
the keywords and and this is what you
want to look for in a good tool you want
to be able to organize your keywords and
label them so for all our brand keywords
we want to be able to label them brand
it because ideally you don't want to
optimize for brand keywords so maybe we
want to exclude our brand keywords and
look at our non brand keywords in terms
of ranking and so you can certainly add
locations and look at specific locations
the whole idea between a good ranking
tool is to be able to measure you know
if a keyword is trending up or down okay
so I can simply look at a tick of a
keyword
I can see the trend of that keyword and
then you know if a keywords not ranking
then we want to wonder why it's not
ranking well is it difficult is it not
ranking because of its difficulty or can
we do a better job of optimizing for
that keyword and so Maas also has a page
optimization tool so if you're not
ranking for keyword you can flip over
the page optimization tool then put in
the keyword put in the URL and Moz will
give you some idea as to what you can
further do to optimize the page okay so
that's Moz you know this is a traps so
you can CH refs does the same thing that
provides you some visibility average
position how much traffic you know where
are you ranking in terms of positions 1
through 3 4 through 10 11 through 50 and
so you want to be able to get a sense of
where my track keywords or trending are
they training up are they training down
and the whole idea again beyond a
ranking tool is if you're trending down
you want to be able to address why it's
trending down so you want to start with
on-page SEO can we do a better job of
optimizing or off page does that page
need more backlinks so that's why you
need a backlink tool to support your
ranking and H refs does offer up some
competitor information as well so you
can see how your competitors are
performing so these are some good
examples of ranking tools that you could
take advantage of now there are also a
few important SEO tools that can be
helpful in different ways for example if
you're doing video so there are some
tools to help you measure how you're
performing via video for example vid IQ
so let's take a look at vid IQ so if I
load in say a video in youtube in this
example how to rank YouTube videos I
have a vid IQ extension loaded into my
browser in Chrome and so now I can get a
good eye sense of how many views the
duration the engagement rate the like
ratio how many people shared it on
reddit but further I can look at how the
video is optimized so they're telling me
the title is too long here maybe shorten
it up but we have tags we have
descriptions we have cards we have end
screens it's been shared on Facebook it
hasn't been shared on Twitter
okay it is public we do have pinned
comments and we do have hearted comments
and so this gives me an idea of how we
did in terms of optimizing this
particular video okay so if we wanted to
tweak it we could tweak the title tag
make it a little bit shorter to help it
rank better on YouTube so you want to be
able to use a tool like this because if
you have videos then you want those
videos to rank and so you can certainly
watch this video on how to rank your
YouTube videos and in that video we do a
looot to vid IQ so you want to be able
to use a tool like this because you know
YouTube it is a video portal but it's a
second largest search engine behind
Google so if you do have videos you want
to be able to rank for them and you want
a tool that's gonna help you measure and
help you understand if you are ranking
if you're not ranking why are you not
ranking now for content optimization
there are tools you can use like SEO
site checkup or site analyzer are some
good tools
if you already have Moz as an example
just going back to Moz as you can
already know I use Mozilla so they have
a page optimization so you can check the
content how your optimize your content
so it's gonna give me some good feedback
on you know is your page title meta
description are they in line okay so
it's gonna give you some good feedback
on that you also have again I have to
allude to search console you can always
look at a particular page in search
console see if it has any errors as well
so is it duplicated Meta Description is
it a duplicated title tag is it any
pages missing title tags your meta
descriptions so when it comes to content
you can look at search console you can
lean on Moz or you can lean on some of
these other paid versions like site
analyzer when it comes to traffic and
metrics look no further than Google
Analytics there is a free version of
Google Analytics as well as a paid
version so if I go into Google Analytics
it's gonna tell me all of my website
behavior ok who's coming to my site how
they got to my site how they behaved
once they went to my site and are they
achieving the goals I set out for them
to achieve via conversions and so you
want to look at Fir
in Google Analytics how much traffic
you're getting so if I go to Google
Analytics if I go to acquisition all
traffic channels I should be able to see
how much traffic organic search is
driving over a period of time so I could
see how many users how many sessions
then if I click on landing pages I can
see what landing page they went to so I
can see the home page over a particular
time and over a thousand sessions I can
also see engagement from organic search
are they bouncing how many pages are
they looking at in this session after
they landed on a particular page are
they staying on the site a long time
what's their duration or and are they
achieving any goals so analytics will
provide me all that information about
how organic search as a channel is
performing the other thing about Google
Analytics I like and that goes back to
the technical aspect of SEO in that site
speed so if you go to behavior and you
go to site speed overview you'll be able
to see how my pages are loading what's
the average load time so they'll break
it down for you by browser by country
and by specific page so if I look at
page timings I'll be able to see what
page is loading slow what page is
loading quick compared to site average
and so the great thing about analytics
is if I have a page that's loading slow
compared to site average they'll
actually provide me with some
suggestions so if I go to site speed and
speed suggestions what they're gonna do
is they're gonna have a link in the
report that's going to allow me to click
on it and I'm gonna be able to see what
suggestions they can provide so when
this report loads I'll be able to see
what the speed suggestions are for my
pages so here I could see a page I could
see what the average load time is of
that page so for example this particular
page is loading at 6 seconds ideally we
want to have you know three seconds or
under maximum so if I just click on this
link here they're giving me six page
speed suggestions so if I click on that
I'm gonna go to another Google tool
called PageSpeed insights and then
PageSpeed insights is going to run for
both mobile and desktop or this
particular page and then this PageSpeed
insights report is gonna give me
feedback as to what I need to
to speed up the low time of that page so
here you can see for desktop and mobile
they're going to give me some
suggestions and opportunities so reduce
the server response time properly size
images serve images in next-gen formats
so all these will shave off time off my
page load time and so that's what's
gonna help me speed up the page load and
that's page being inside you can get to
from the speed suggestions report and
analytics so in theory the higher page
load time your chances of ranking on
Google organic search diminished so
Google wants pages that have very low
page load time that load quickly so
Google Analytics is great tool for Speed
suggestions it's a great tool for
finding out what the traffic is doing on
your site how they're engaging and are
they achieving goals now there are other
tools out there from an organic
perspective like keyword it that's a
good keyword research tool for reddit so
if you go to keyword it you'll be able
to see from a reddit perspective what
keywords are driving volume these are
just the results but you can put any
keyword in there and get the results of
that keyword so thank you for paying
attention we hope some of these tools
were useful for you if you have any
other suggestions on any tools we didn't
mention in this video then please feel
free to add them to the comments section
below of this video we look forward to
getting your comments and we'll respond
accordingly thank you again and if you
have any more information or need any
more information please visit simply
learn com
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here